With more people living and
working, in and around Rangiora,
there's increased pressure on car parking.
It's estimated that within the next 30 years
we'll require up to 800 new car parking spaces.
The Council has already bought and leased land
in the town centre here for parking but long
term that's not going to be enough and so we're
looking at constructing a car parked building.
We've already set aside 6 million in
a previous Long Term Plan but we'll
need more than that to meet future demand.
The council was proposing another 9 million
dollars from 2028 and that's for a building that's
going to provide up to 280 additional car parks.
Alternatively we could bring forward
funding and build it sooner or defer
the project all together and look at
other options for managing parking.
Visit waimakariri.govt.nz/letstalk to take
a look at the options and to have your say.